so last time uh
commissioner i remember seeing you in
public anyway and i know there's been
other times since then
i saw you at the las vegas city council
meeting this is some time ago now
and you were discussing with mayor
goodman and others about working in
collaboration with coronavirus and
getting unified and things along those
lines getting businesses open
a lot's changed since then how would you
characterize
how clark county and the cities in the
county
are working together now to try and get
our the hand on the pandemic
you know we're working really well
together that's why we're rolling out
our testing tomorrow at the texas
and additional strike teams that we'll
go out and test within
communities so we've been working really
well we're doing a little bit over
5 000 inspections a week
across the valley so we are um
we've come a long ways in a short time
and i think
that uh we'll continue to work together
because we're
we're going to be in this for a while
you mentioned that
and the latest numbers you know the
cases are going up we saw what governor
sislak said
about sort of the stay at home 2.0
how is the county going to be able to
balance public health
with apparently not closing more not
closing businesses again certainly not
the las vegas strip
how are you gonna be able to walk that
balance that walk that fine line
so we've been walking that balance for a
very long time and we have to look at
public health bars
but public health also is economic and
social
health and mental health so we are um
we have a bunch of great folks here in
clark county they've really been
stepping up and doing the extra efforts
i get that people are covert fatigue i
think we could all
agree to that but we're going into flu
season now and we
really have to make sure that our
behaviors
are top-notch i mean this is the time we
always knew that
as the weather got colder that
we would see more cases um because
that's just naturally what happens to us
during flu season so
what i would tell you is the best thing
that we can all do to keep businesses
open to keep our community healthy
is to just pay extra special attention
to
washing your hands wearing a face mask
and social distancing
and that and i'm confident that we value
staying open that we can do that
in the next few weeks is it possible for
clark county to
step in and close businesses on its own
again
so we have um so we have uh
we've been shutting down businesses that
have not been complying not trying to
comply
uh for the last i don't know seven
months
so we did have a small miscommunication
of whose jurisdiction was what but i'll
tell you that
all of the business licensing across the
valley
including osha gaming control board
the athletic commission are all uh
meeting once a week
and we're looking at where our problems
are
i guess i meant more broadly if there
was going to be i remember the governor
had the phases
early on in the pandemic is it possible
that
clark county could on its own if cases
continue to increase and there's more of
a public health concern
step in and shut down let's say
bars or restaurants or close down
gyms and athletic facilities things
along those lines we can always be more
restrictive
than the governor's directive we can
also go to the mitigation task force and
recommend some
some of those closures but i can tell
you this has been very hard for
everybody
you know we have to balance people being
able to pay their bills
as well as businesses who are trying to
stay afloat
during these tough times and so
i'm just hoping that with the public
health that people will really
um really pay attention so you know some
of the things that we're seeing are
unregulated businesses that are creating
the problem
you know so whether it's a group of
people getting on a bus and renting a
house and
partying all night with no face mask or
whether it's
your law firm that's hosting a luncheon
with no social distancing no face masks
no washing your hands
those are the things that i need people
to pay attention to
um for the next three to four months
because it is our flu season and we
always have to make sure that our
hospitals do not get overrun
speaking of money uh we were discussing
there i saw something on the clark
county on the agenda for this coming
week with regards to
uh coronavirus relief funding and i
think it was 290 or so million dollars
that the county received i might have
the numbers a little bit wrong there but
the bottom line was
from what i could tell it's referenced
that there was unused
money um i i guess where has the money
gone and
who else in the county needs that
financial assistance right now
so we do have a large uh pot of money
set aside for
folks that are in jeopardy of being
evicted
because we want to try and help pay that
so we can stabilize them and keep them
in a location
so we are working through those those
dollars go quickly
uh this is really is just an update to
see where the money is gone
regionally we all set aside money for
our search capacity
uh that is why we rolled out free
testing for everybody so that everybody
can come get
so that's a little over 12 million
dollars
we still have supplies and those things
to do so
i'm confident that i won't be giving a
check back because there are so many
needs
that um we're even stepping up efforts
to help some of these other businesses
that are just
uh not able to stay uh caught up
on their bills through this time i guess
the question would just be if a
community the size of clark county has
unused funds if there's a need
to ask for more federal assistance for
example if if the money that's already
been dished out hasn't all been used
do you need would there be a need for
more
well and here's what i would tell you
it's apples and oranges because the
dollars that we got today were
specifically
to building the needs of a community
during these times but for local
government in particular
and state government there's a lost
revenue component
because this money has to be expended by
december 30th
so we know that january 1st there's
going to be tons of evictions that are
on the
chopping block we know that coronavirus
we're still going to be in the middle of
it
until we can get the vaccine here
so we're still going to have needs and
with that lost revenue
on the local and state level we we still
have to provide service so when times
are bad we provide
lots of service when times are good we
still have to provide
service and the legislative session
won't be easy either funding wise uh
down the pipe no and we get a large um
portion of our social service dollars
from the state
so we are watching that very closely
because
we still have to provide all those
services final question
um you won re-election obviously
congratulations to you
um there is a bit of a
changing face on the board so some of
the people on the commission have turned
out
how has the election or will the
election
alter how the body moves forward
oh no absolutely not i mean
we think that we have a strategic plan
that we put in place
last year so we're still in the middle
of that strategic plan
and it's going to be a lot of catch up
for anybody new that comes to the county
there's 38 departments
there's thousands of employees so
there's
lots of things so we'll work we have
training in place
we kind of give them an over brief of
what's going on and
they'll have their own ideas and we'll
embrace them and
continue to move our county forward but
right now public health is our biggest
component
of the county uh but we have been
keeping some of our other things going
um along the way and we
we have to be able to do both finally
finally um
i want to readdress what's something i'm
asked at the very beginning with regards
to
the county and the city of las vegas at
the beginning of the pandemic you
remember
some of the uh conversations that were
had by mayor goodman and some of the
opinions of those at city hall didn't
seem necessarily in line with clark
county
and i think it seemed like there was an
effort to try and address that
you know months ago how would you
characterize the relationship now
between clark county and city hall
specific to
covid response so here's what i would
tell you we've come light years
in just eight months uh everybody is
working very closely together
the cities in general the mayor and i
speak on a regular basis
you know she was one of the first
entities to call me
regarding election safety what could she
do to help and so i think that
this has brought us closer we're like
brothers and sisters in this valley
we can get mad at each other but we
don't hold it because we know that we
have a responsibility as leaders
to move our county forward and that is
something that makes nevada special